Say you look at just two polygons from the side. A red one and a yellow one.
Because they interpenetrate. The draw order will always be wrong for one pixel
or another. If the yellow object is drawn first, this upper pixel will have the
wrong order of yellow, then red. If the red object is drawn first, the lower
pixel has the same problem. Red than yellow. For the first answer, with the
yellow object being rendered first, there's no red object for it to blend with.
So this answer is correct. Blending has not been turned off for the yellow
object since you can see the grid lines through it. So this answer is wrong. The
yellow object blocks the red object at the top so it must have been drawn first
and written to the z-buffer. So this answer is also wrong. The fourth answer is
correct. The transparency algorithm states that the more distant object, the
yellow one, is drawn first. Another way to think about it is that you can have
red over yellow, or yellow over red, but not both at the same time.